don't ever be ashamed of anything you've
done in your life face it fix it make it
better build belief build confidence to
the point where nothing can hurt you
because you know exactly who you are
you've faced your demons in your mind
you were able to hear all your past
traumas you're able to listen to them
you're able to say okay now I can now
talk to people about what I went through
I'm no longer embarrassed I'm no longer
ashamed being ashamed is one of the
biggest things that people nowadays in
their minds kill them from moving
forward I'm ashamed of myself we are
humans but then again if you always
think that we're humans you will always
just be a human and always make the same
mistakes so I'm just trying to give
people that strength while you're
probably up is probably something
happened to you in your life go through
the archives dig it up study it and then
use it for yourself that's the main
purpose for me right now